it's the end of an era literally i can't
believe it
you got the new record coming out august
13th and i got to tell you the track
list at least on paper it looks like you
got some wild stories to tell so i mean
what's the vibe of the album
i mean sonically it's kind of just a
mashup of all the different sounds that
i've played with throughout my musical
career there's a lot of electronic
elements a lot of big heavy miami 80s
synths and then of course always
the heavy 808 like hip-hop
drums that you kind of
have heard and fancy and those kinds of
like big hits that i've had
then narrative wise i'm always talking
my [ __ ] but
then i'm also just kind of drawing from
past stories of crazy [ __ ] that i used
to do when i was in my early 20s did you
always know that this was gonna be the
one before taking a break from music or
did it just kind of evolve into that as
you started creating
i had an idea
like was this part of the big picture
yeah i always felt that you know i
i had other creative things that i
really wanted to kind of get to yeah and
it's hard to get to them when you're a
recording artist i think now is a good
time for me to kind of
say everything that i need to say and
then take my step away and focus on some
other creative things i am a gemini so i
never like to say things super
definitively but yeah this is my last
album on my distribution deal so i don't
have an obligation to write anymore but
this is an our contractual obligation
putting out this album this was so
important to me and i really took my
time with it because i'm like this may
be the last one
and i'm pretty sure it will be so i just
really wanted to make it something that
i was so happy with and
that i can live with loving the cover
loving every song and for me it's a no
skip album for me no skip album she said
it okay i like it that much i lay in bed
and listen to it all the time and i just
love it i may come back in three or four
years and decide that there's something
more that i have to say or to offer but
at this point in my
life i feel a little bit um less willing
to share certain personal things or the
now with my relationships or how i'm
feeling because i am on such
an intense spotlight that you know in my
early 20s when i was originally making
music or writing songs i could be like
this person blah blah blah and it was
different because nobody knew who i was
talking about
and now they're connecting the dots yeah
now everybody connects the dots and i
feel a little less willing to share
things like that but i also think that
being um vulnerable in those ways or
being willing to share those things is
part of connecting with you know
your fan base and there are other ways
that i want to connect with them now my
decision to not make any more music is
ultimately
really at this point truly 95 of it is
about the fact that i
i just don't feel that i
am comfortable being that level
open to the public i
am
you know i maybe it's partially because
i have a son now and i feel that
maternal instinct to want to really like
protect
him and have that like space safe space
and i don't really want to invite um
strangers
to have an opinion about my life so much
anymore so it's more about that but also
you know i
i really don't want to tour anymore
because i have my son and i'm so excited
i'm going on this big pitbull tour that
starts on the 19th actually which is
like my last big hurrah i'll still do
spot dates and things like that but in
terms of like an aggressive tour where
you're away all the time i don't
want my son to be transient in that way
always on a tour bus or if you know i
admire people that do it and do it well
but for me that's not my vision for my
future family yeah
and so i think that there are just a lot
of elements now with my life changing
that i don't see myself doing all the
time this tour i'm really excited about
because i get to bring my son on
some of the tour
um so i don't really have to be without
him more than four or five days so that
works but as these old earnings in
school and things like that i don't
think it's very fair to him so i
want to try to just like shift my focus
onto things that can
mesh better with where i'm where i'm at
in my life i want to know how's
motherhood treating you
uh you know what new milestones has onyx
crossed and reached
oh my gosh onyx is so tall he like got
his measurement two days ago and i was
like oh my god this kid is he's already
three foot one and he's only good
he's so he's gonna be a giant
um but he's amazing he's great are we
about to see less of onyx i know you've
uh said that you're not posting them on
social media yeah for a little while i
think that's what's best because there
are just so many trolls and um
oh i found somebody showed me this like
really awful reddit thread that was just
like a bunch of weird
people
um like making memes and
about your kids about my son yeah
and i just felt really um
weirded out to be honest with you about
it as a parent uh that was really
uncomfortable and weird for me and so i
don't blame you seeing that was kind of
like
the straw that broke the camel's back
for me where i was like oh no i don't i
can't sign him up to keep providing
content
for this weird group of people um no
yeah no i don't blame you on that at all
i still post him on my close friend's
stories on instagram so you know i'm
like everything i want to see
onyx is seeing onyx all the time but i
have to it's my job it's not that it
necessarily hurts my feelings i'm a
grown up but i it's my job to protect my
son as a mother so i i when i see
something like that that's so extreme
i'm like i really have to
i would love to share him all the time
but that wouldn't be really me
protecting him knowing that that's
what's going on so i can't do that
you're in mama bear mode i get it i am
i'm like i will fight someone for him
[Music]